so for me the best part actually one of
the best parts of the course was having
students presents parts of the material
and and and there was one challenge is
that often there was a temptation to
just do a summary of what you had read
but the point was not just give a
summary was to be able to integrate the
readings with the larger so I call it
the drum of ideas and I used that based
on previous readings that we have done
earlier in previous years on this on
this course of this course and but that
wasn't always easy because there is a
big difference between doing a summary
and then taking the ideas of your
readings and then incorporating them
into into your own reading of the course
into personal issues into communal or
critical issues and for me I wanted them
to be able to do that too and and the
motive for that which was basically
reading by Paulo Freire a and Italo
Macedo was as you read the word you also
have to read the world and so it's not
enough to just look at the text as if
it's a text you have to be able to
connect the text with issues of
actuality and which could be personal
which could be political which could be
international and and at the end they
did get to do that and sometimes the
most beautiful moving often after well
it can pay personal they would pick up
personal issues about the upbringing
which would connect to the linguistic
biography so from it was a very
rewarding part of the course is to is to
see them being able to make those
connections between abstract complex
analysis and what they live from day by
day basis